welcome to podcast Ville to the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by my book e dot AG yes my book e dot AG
let me tell you something everybody
needs some holiday cash you need it and
I know where to get it
my book E is the place to score serious
cash on your sports predictions believe
it or not the holidays or what down the
corner right three four or five days
away we can have we're not even what
means you know that means parties gifts
and spending Jesus [ __ ] it also means
there's lots of football college bowls
basketball NBA hockey that means you can
make money every [ __ ] day understand
me living like a doctor but listen if
you want to make money betting games you
got to go to my bookie dot AG they're
the only side I'd recommend I trust them
but you don't take my word for it
check them out yourself they have odds
on every matchup and a mobile site that
makes wagering on your smartphone or
breeze what I'm gonna do is this join
now and my bookie will match your
deposit well up to a 50% bonus that's
right 50% bonus use promo code Church CH
you are CH to activate the offer visit
my bookie down a g10 a right now and use
promo code Church listen you play you
win and most importantly you get paid
Jack
number two the holidays are coming
enough is enough how long we can you
walk around with that filthy [ __ ] ass
and that ball sack that smells like
[ __ ] white cider vinegar how long
will you continue to walk around with
that rotten dingleberry hanging from
that [ __ ] muffler then you sit here
you go I can't find the date on
match.com cuz they can smell your ass
through the speaker on the [ __ ]
computer you nasty [ __ ] but I'm
here to help you know why cuz hello
fishy comm is the way to go hello - she
has a beautiful portable bidet
that's not song tali toilet in less than
ten [ __ ] minutes
all right so no more walking around with
stinky [ __ ] no more habit to sneak a
scratch when nobody's looking and sniff
your fingers those days are over
you're gonna get yourself a cushy you
know why they started $69 and they comes
in all types of colors so stop wiping
with that [ __ ] nasty toilet paper and
get a clean ass with tushy hello tushy
calm and use promo code church for 10%
off your order
take that [ __ ] mule Lee thank you for
putting on the church what's happened
now I got the beautiful talented Kate
Quigley thank you my skill if you look
up [ __ ] Pontius Pilate looks a little
lightly we love bad boys you said you
did you did you do 23andme go I don't
need to Pontius Pilate is my
great-great-great-great granddaughter
that's the only time anyone ever said I
look like a bad boy so take care what
you look great by the way cleaned up go
to the gym he's dressed up for you
things you've been going to the gym no I
got it I got a butt I got a polo shirt
on Amazon I have tons of polo shirt ah
but the last podcast this is a good
color you look like a Navy man let's go
LM looking with the black deaths right
he's gonna kill Kate [ __ ] it needs it
it's a little sad lonely because I see
you cake quick you to happen I love you
when did I see you last I'm trying to
think are you birthday party I feel bad
don't follow jeez you know when you get
out of sometimes they get in the [ __ ]
car problem with people talking for two
or three hours and you have like nine
missed calls some people you have to
pick up the phone yeah quietly when they
get out of it but my friends from Jersey
they don't understand that [ __ ] so when
I got the car I had to call one of them
back and they got to talking and next
you know I'm on [ __ ] Laurel Canyon my
[ __ ] I couldn't even believe you were
gonna Kong I try I don't even listen I
don't do dick I know I hate all those
people over there if you're over 12 why
don't call the birthday parties they're
like I know that well that's why when
you said I was your special type of
having me so I love you yet sometimes
you have to go out of the norm and break
your little cushion but I never break
plus if we're gonna drive by it on the
way back from on the way home really
yeah yeah let me [ __ ] go over this
say hello yeah I did it at saddle ranch
which is like two blocks from the Comedy
Store and The Laugh Factory so I was
like everyone will stop by honestly it
was the best birthday I was depressed
because I'm getting old and I was like I
don't know I don't even want to
celebrate it but then I decided to and
then everyone came like I couldn't
believe you know sometimes you don't
realize like how many people care and
then you do something like that like
some of the people that showed up Terry
you know Jack Jr who was on you had
checked his mom who owns the haha comedy
club came
she's like you like she doesn't go to
[ __ ] she's like 60 years old she [ __ ]
put on makeup and a hot outfit you dress
up dude she looked amazing and she even
went to the wrong saddle ranch first at
Universal and then realized and then
came all the way over the hill to the
other saddle ranch and she partied she
got drunk it's just like flirting she
was amazing so I was like super touched
she came my ex-boyfriend came who I
thought hated me and I couldn't believe
he showed up and then oh and then I got
a surprise birthday present in the mail
today from Dustin Penner I have to give
him a shout-out do you know who he is he
played hockey for the kings and the
Ducks right he sent me a magic wand
vibrator in the mail I came to my mail
today I opened it I was like this is
amazing so it's been like I feel loved
it felt good
nice fun we gave you a nice present okay
we like guys gave me a great gift thank
you I'm gonna show that like yeah it's
good to see you you go [ __ ] to The
Hollies you're not going old flowers no
I'm gonna stay here this they're gonna
get [ __ ] drilled next week the East
Coast really snow yeah is that they're
saying that's great though I have your
[ __ ] flying in there well that's true
but have you flown it in I like
Christmas to be snowy though we all do
we all do but then but swell [ __ ]
hours for it to be snowy you know what
come to the house we'll free some ice
it's fight it's crazy because I just I
don't know I would love to take the baby
of my wife back to our parents and
Tennessee like horizon
but the Empson madam wait always [ __ ] -
[ __ ] storms that means delays even if
there's not storms honestly every year I
say I'm in a state because one Christmas
yeah no you go back one year last year I
went back but like only one Christmas I
stayed here I've gone back every year
cuz I I love my mom and I mean she
always kinda she doesn't mean to Joyce
guilt trips me you know about not coming
back so like she I'll tell her I can't
afford it and then she'll be like I
totally understand but then every time I
do anything should be like I saw you had
a couple drinks last night who paid for
those can you put that towards your
plane ticket so I always end up going
but one year I stayed here it was the
best Christmas I ever had not that I
don't love my family but I went surfing
I kicked it at the beach I ate Mexican
food and then I went to karaoke with a
bunch of comics and then I ended up
kissing stranger it was awesome it was
like the best Christmas ever
so this year I decided to do it again
I'm staying here I'm not gonna go home
I'm gonna serve food at the Laugh
Factory and then pray go to the beach
that's it you know it's kind of weird
when you have like a rough year and the
holidays are gonna come up and you're
like I don't gonna survive them you know
and you know like [ __ ]
and then Thanksgiving is always like a
half one maybe then the huncle that died
[ __ ] made stuffing or something but
you know the holidays coming you expect
to feel really shitty and something
weird happens that you end up feeling
good that's what the holidays are yes
like feeling good by mistake it's true
like this year actually Thanksgiving it
was funny cuz I was supposed to go do a
gig and then at the last minute
something came up with the gig and it
got cancelled so I ended up being in LA
with no plans like I found out the day
before it was canceled so then I didn't
know what to do I woke up Thanksgiving
morning with no plan and I text my
girlfriend who's new in town was like
what are you gonna do today
and she's like I don't know and I was
like you know do you want to just go to
the beach and like [ __ ] around she's
like sure so I put on a turkey suit like
an actual full turkey costume and we
went to the beach and I tried to surf
wearing a turkey outfit which I'm a
horrible surfer but like I like to try
and we took photos of it and then I like
played with little kids
and then we went to again we went to a
taco joint drank margaritas but no
Turkey nothing that resembled
Thanksgiving but it was like so fun and
in some way it's being here for the
holidays cuz I grew up in Ohio so being
here where it's like sunny and warm it
doesn't even feel like I'm missing a
holiday I can forget so easily that it's
even a holiday it's just no traffic it's
just a nice day with no traffic that's
it but I was so happy I think I like
being away from family for the holidays
that's what I decide there's no stress
and I can drop by in the summer and
surprise everyone with gifts for no
reason and then I'm just like the cool
aunt that came home and like gave out
gifts and money for no reason instead of
just being like there at the holidays
where no one even remembers that you
came you know what I mean and then I'm
sad so I'm the only one single and the
only one without kids and then my mom
will be like who are you dating now and
then I have to like list off the whole
you know team just kidding
solely joking but yes holidays up I
first I didn't think I could survive the
holidays without like being in Jersey
like I still moved my first Christmas
out of Jersey was like heartbreaking but
then I woke up Christmas damn ago you
know I'm saw a bird I'm gonna go skiing
I never skied before wide ski too I put
skis on one time where were you the
first time I ski was at the Playboy
Resort in New Jersey with a bunch of
[ __ ] morons doing blow and we didn't
even ski I had a playboy resort like a
playboy ski thing this is a yellow on
that midnight scan oh I love know what
at midnight you gotta you know midnight
wait the weather's like you know I
didn't say please I didn't think that
would happen I see that's like when you
with the zipline you didn't think it out
you're the same I didn't think it out
I'm like wait a second it's [ __ ] 10
above the deal zero Oh
in the daytime and I'm going to the
[ __ ] mountains to [ __ ] ski and I
didn't even think about I went with
jeans or like a t-shirt oh yeah I was a
real fun it was your first time yes you
my god and prepare for it you know
the ionizer my wife of the babies oh
look at this neon is 100 kids from the
school have you know I just [ __ ] know
who won the hockey games when I was a
kid that yeah whenever you go to
anything with a hockey ice it's called a
bring a [ __ ] jacket yeah well I just
know this in my head but I don't share
would be because I think everybody else
knows distance oh god don't tell me your
wife didn't bring any we get in the
[ __ ] car
and while we're driving she goes oh my
god my friend just called me from the
school and 7:00 I hope I bring a jacket
for me and Marissa cause we're gonna be
cold and I go you didn't know that I
could I even know this mercy had like a
little hooded sweatshirt on Oh God
but she took it off she was great well
she's a kid they don't feel anything
shorts in the snow anything when does
that add it like now I feel and now I'm
like cold all the time as a kid I would
just stand outside [ __ ] yeah I was
telling my friend of Villota
and we were kids he had a shed and the
shed had no heat and we would go back
there you know the night started at a
villa shed it's not long the dead but
every night started a petition from the
time I was in the eighth grade to maybe
uh maybe six months after I quit high
school her low shed was always a haven
it was big he painted the walls he had
sat a bloody Sabbath on one more I don't
know he had volume four on one wall he
had the wall Pink Floyd on one wall he
had a drum kit in there and the marshal
lamb nice and if you got too cold just
play the drums dude I remember as a kid
the people that like some of my
neighbors had those sheds and their
parents would like give it to them as
like a clubhouse and I was so jealous I
just wanted to live in one tremendous
yeah
you freeze no Wintle you want a drink
back there you give a freeze I don't
know we guys are talking about my
everything I ever was that had like
bikes and like equipment in this week
you didn't have like friends that had
like a little cog house in the back they
closed it off and they had a door no so
was it an extra apartment in the back
yes
the floors linoleum that [ __ ] you
install on your own
and we went back there five nights a
week his mother would never go back then
bother us hate the boys told a mod do us
a favor yell back to embarrass us yell
for us and we'll walk well isn't isn't
that the place where you had the punch
with the bees in it yes so maybe they
should have wait hundred bees in it one
of the first parties I went there was
there was three of them there was
Michael Anthony and Stephen okay I was
friends with Stephen but the real cool
one was Anthony and Michael was older he
was already out of that whole scene yeah
so when I was like a [ __ ] freshman I
was old I had to be yeah because my
mother was still alive and I went over
there like at 8 o'clock and it was me
stinky and a villa or the only kids that
were allowed at that party that the
older guys would let it because we were
with his brother so though I was just
last yeah Saturday night I didn't go
uptown I went over there not thinking
anything and they would move type of
guys always punch him then they saw yeah
they would all come over [ __ ] punch
what uh come on give him a [ __ ] drink
can't do that now guys Bobby me too and
they [ __ ] got a cup it was like I
have my cup right there and they stuck
just go put your hand on the punch and
they you just put your hand in the punch
a thousand hands I've been in that punch
garbage-can weather with a liner but the
garbage can was still dirty
the last factory holidays they filled it
in with [ __ ] every booze imaginable
on me oh my god fruit and then they put
bees in their knees and some of the
people eat the [ __ ] bees I started
drinking that magic punch and at the end
they told the state that they duped it
with something like acid or something
nice but I was a young kid
wait the bees though I had no idea I've
never I've never been to a [ __ ] me I
don't [ __ ] know I think that there's
like poison there's like some peas that
make you hire bees in that [ __ ] thing
so all I remember is drinking with them
having a great time and the next thing
you know I open my eyes and I mom and
then the Sun is halfway out and a cop is
standing over me with a stick name is
rayon that's toe the cops name was Ray
on that stone when I was on Ritchie
since chulos one cuz I have no reason to
I was just on his lawn how'd you know
the cops names because you play
basketball when I'm at the courts oh you
already knew we were kids he was the
only gonna had the audacity to show up
would sneak isn't colored socks so we
would torment them people would leave
[ __ ] way and that's though showed up
with colored socks walking oh my gosh
the kids in my neighborhood was strict
about that rule no colored socks at the
courts bro what why cuz you bring bad
luck they tell you that in high school
in the seventies and eighties is so
weird if you had colored socks in my
high school when you went to gym class
they would send you no gym today you're
kidding no I would have want colored
socks on purpose it fell you because if
you cut your foot bank from the sock I'm
living for the cut poison I swear to God
my school was anti colored socks for
anything used to make socks white socks
white with red stripe color the white
socks don't they yeah well but not that
gotta be [ __ ] and white that's it they
bleached white that would - right never
mind the stripe but colors are socks
just naturally when they make on white
off-white page does it [ __ ] matter
my point is I know white but they
weren't whiter my point is they want the
[ __ ] wash that it live with let us
what say that wasn't my just my school
that was a bunch of school districts
[ __ ] I would wear [ __ ] neon socks
every the only time you go away college
socks if you played baseball with those
black baseball socks with the little
beggars was only one inch on your heel
what do you think your gym teacher would
say if he saw one of those like toe
socks things well they'd throw you out
of it first of all one of the kids in
the class would be to the death before
he was before that we didn't play like
that duck
play like that we take Jim seriously
they took everything have stupid rules
for no reason Ronnie like Jojo and
that's all Joey rules are the rules
[ __ ] I grew up with odd written
rules there were rules and can I just
tell you I can't say where but I just
did a comedy show tell me if this has
ever happened you I just did a comedy
show somewhere where they made you turn
in your ID when you got there and take
an employee badge and you were not
allowed to drink until the show was over
at all they took your ID so you couldn't
buy alcohol anywhere and I was so
annoyed so I'm like I'm a grown-up
I don't even normally drink before I go
up but I was so annoyed that I went and
found alcohol and drank just to be like
[ __ ] the system because they said I
couldn't drink and I think it's so dumb
so I went and bought tequila you make
the decision to become a musician when
you make the decision to give up your
Denari life an American life to become a
musician or an artist or the paint want
to do calm and all that [ __ ] guess what
man some job rules don't apply to you
that's how I felt okay why you think I'm
so [ __ ] burnt out because probably
comedy is this thing that you do it's a
grind and you know but it's this thing
that you do when you fall in love with
you obsess with and then it turns into
something else it turns into a business
and that business wears on your psyche
because you're an artist you don't you
know all you wanna do is make people
laugh you're so right you just don't
make people have an awesome it becomes
just no you can't perform there because
there's not enough seats what are you
talking about that's why I still get
beat up for doing a punch line in San
Francisco and every time they call me
with an offer they try to sneak it by me
yes we're gonna get you in carbs listen
and I finally had to send them Wigan
though the next time you tell me about
cops don't talk to me about those boy
you're right Wednesdays don't talking
about Thursdays that's the struggle that
makes your brain I know you hate Sundays
I'm talking in my Sunday there's no
reason we should have us out there you
want us out there come come fly out and
do the [ __ ] show of me at 7:00 see
how miserable is to miss every flight by
one hour because so
sure you know yes you can't even take a
[ __ ] redeye in this country anymore
there needs to be more midnight the last
flight out of LAX is 1259 when I was
growing up we you could take at 3:30 is
Chicago right actually 3:30 in the
morning a 3000 you could think of it in
those airports you were flying into that
[ __ ] all night long dress all
right you get the 4:00 a.m. to Miami it
is interesting though because you're so
right I mean like it exhausts you you
just want to make art that's it I get so
tired because my brain I'm so
overwhelmed with all the business side
of everything everything's a business
and everything I know what you want to
do I have a book of a job one time guys
you come buddy
you're [ __ ] bro you're fighting every
month you fight so bright okay you break
it down to the month and then you learn
to break it down for the day I was down
to the day I lived for the day I had it
down to it's today you don't know what's
gonna happen cuz that this little
promoter I used to call me this big fat
black milk and he'd always give me a
loan so I got a deposit for you can you
always me and Felipe we used to always
take this 500 and then he call us
something the dog like cancel the gig
then he calls back two weeks letting the
listen I got another date and I send
this in deposit your [ __ ] ain't
right no dog that the pop you've got to
have it yeah what yeah date you [ __ ]
been in the South for before do you know
how broke I was when I first moved to LA
I got this [ __ ] studio apartment in
now it's like where the target is in
West Hollywood Santa Monica and La Brea
back then it was so ghetto it was all
hookers and crackheads you know where
the target is yes the target was there
yeah this was like 11 12 years ago right
I was so broke I rented this place I
sight unsink sigh need enough I have one
day to find an apartment I was in my car
sleeping in my car so I rent this place
it was section 8 housing I didn't know
yeah I didn't even know it had a pool
though that's why I took it it was the
only place I could afford with a pool so
as a [ __ ] it I'll take it the pool by
the way I definitely had like AIDS
swimming in it like it was the grossest
dirtiest pool I take this apartment no
furniture I go in there with an air
mattress I had a TV tray for like a
quote desk no TV nothing I'm sleeping on
the floor
on the air mattress after a couple days
I go to the grocery store to buy food I
waited like three days I have no money
to get paid for a job I go to buy food I
come home with all my groceries and I
realize that I didn't have a fridge
because apartments in LA don't always
come with the fridge so what a friend
but I didn't even notice there was no
fridge don't come with stoves yeah I was
so exhausted from just like moving here
and I was already auditioning I hit the
ground [ __ ] running like auditioning
acting classes I spent all my money on
that I come home with these [ __ ] two
bags that I like walked home seven
blocks and I get there and I have no
fridge so then I all my [ __ ] went bad
because I couldn't afford a fridge and
then like a week later I bought like a
dorm fridge off some dude off Craigslist
for like 20 bucks that had like mold
growing in it I was so poor but I was
the happiest I'd ever been like I lived
like that for six months with no
furniture but I was doing I started
doing stand-up and I got lucky and I
booked a gig right away on a TV show
just one day but so I felt like oh I'm
in the right place I'm gonna make it
they already love me I booked a job and
then after that I booked nothing for
like two years yeah
and I was so poor I booked a pilot a
[ __ ] commercial that's something else
and then the wall dried up I couldn't
[ __ ] book a headshot and my manager
was really good at the time and I broke
up with that girl me and her got into a
fight in the [ __ ] Street and I took a
flight to Miami like a week later I
stayed in Miami for six weeks and just
how some seed and he paid me like 300 a
week I spelled like 400 week it was
[ __ ] craziness and then you know you
saw I was tell him how when I first got
here I couldn't find an agent trying to
sign with an agency called a coloring
book it was too black Jeff what was a
really badass attorney no bad lethal
Leto
like whatever she booked you a job you
were getting paid like hey that's good
because she know all the numbers she's
still an agent I'll take her though
both left the one agent what that was my
age and I love to deal we our husband
cheated on her with a white chick so she
moved back to DC with the kids fella one
the husband cheated on though the white
chick and she moved back to Atlanta so
they they used to keep in touch for
years
have you ever get something let us in on
it but the reason why I stopped talking
to one I really liked her was because
when reality got really hot I was here
right before the bull Rogan was already
a fear factor the first year and it was
off and running
yeah I was at this agency called PJ
Linder and associates they were our
hosts agent let me tell you something
every day there might you blows up
Spanish shows that's tell American shows
they didn't give a [ __ ] and one of the
shows when they got me a meeting with
this guy I don't know what his name was
but he was gayer than [ __ ] and I
started talking talking talking and
finally because you know what when you
speak it just my soul was telling me all
this [ __ ] this is what we're gonna do
did you get casting couch please tell me
please can I judge off in front of a
plant he was he was really soft guy he
looked like not a tough guy but he
looked like a little assertive guy but
after ten minutes I just broke him what
do you mean all the feathers became
flying out what do you mean you broke
because I was telling he was asking
these strawberries and I was telling
stories about my childhood and he was
kind of like getting teary-eyed and [ __ ]
and I broke him my straw and he goes oh
my god I kind of grew up the same way I
was you know I was like I'm like all
this guy's gay and [ __ ] I didn't give
a [ __ ] I'm gonna do me
death are the first people that really
listen and he goes you know what I have
these friends and he got right in front
of me he got on the phone he goes hey
man you gotta stop putting that game
together a game show and they go
taking minor but we had a bump and he
goes what's the bump and he goes well we
don't know who the cast who we really
want once a lot of money he goes who you
want to cast us in right what game shows
us it was a game show where you go out
to dinner we are teaming and we
burglarize your house shut up something
just that's a game show
this is business it was like a reality
how do you win NBC it was [ __ ] mb at
that time they didn't know what was
gonna happen
you burglarized that so they was not me
me me that me hold on so they were
picking up they were picking up
everything okay quickly they didn't know
what reality was gonna buy they didn't
know that that the Bachelorette was
gonna be popular sure they did not know
these things so this was a slash what
would he call those things one of those
cars and a half electric half high thing
this was gonna be a Harvard show you
never seen in like the early 2000s with
two guys who are breaking into houses
this is a show where a family went out
we got their alarm codes to your house
and I was the host of the show
and these people broke into your house
and then how did you get your stuff back
the kids come home they're like crying
like all their [ __ ] is gone be really
weird and then what's the game show like
taking place inside the house but the
game show like how did how far can you
be pushed before you kill yourself I
remember these guys but they had me at
Paramount in front of a [ __ ] like the
whole like right away like wait three
weeks later this [ __ ] thing started
and they're like you're the man they
came to see me at the store they stayed
for two spots and they're like yo that
is perfect for you they're like you're
lost so we go back we go back and forth
now they want to do a screen test for
the network so we go to Paramount and I
get up on stage and the lights are
behind me in the houses and I gotta do
this [ __ ] spiel right so okay the
show's gonna go I had a manager had an
agent at the time my agent was good
but my manager was just brilliant he was
just brilliant I was too bad to be with
him yeah yeah yeah he was all the towns
like yeah he had no business sign of me
but he thought that he could get a show
I still feel like that now like he
thought I could get a show yeah so he
was powerful as [ __ ]
well [ __ ] he wakes me up the next
morning guys I'm broke as [ __ ]
okay I'm Terry seven hundred we can't
make it
we got three or four cats you know you
ready verse guys pick up a call Blaine
Joey Jeff how you doing I talked to
those people last night I got them up to
15,000 an episode for the pilot and if
the show goes you're gonna pick up
twenty seven five holy [ __ ] first time
on TV for the episodes per episode holy
[ __ ] thirteen episode commitment oh did
you wanna listen to me bro I'm telling
your [ __ ] story lovin' you homie broke
the [ __ ] again this one on this one adds
like a day and a half then I got a call
from my agent there's gonna happen to
you can quickly write for this lease I
had broke Lee you're broke you just had
to borrow money from your father you're
about to borrow money from your mother
as your agent calls you and tells you
got a meeting and next thing you know
they want to do a show and you're the
host on MBC that [ __ ] oxygen or
[ __ ] modeling Central you've been here
for two [ __ ] years Lee two years
you've been here and MBC is already
marking and your manager just calls you
and says to you listen to me they're
gonna give you 15,000 for the pilot and
if the show gets picked up which we have
so much power around it
he's gonna get 27,000 episode for the
first season okay Lee you're gonna hang
up the phone call your mother
I'm Paul Reiser okay I'm [ __ ] the
less static okay gotta be C wants to see
me again
back down in Paramount I don't know why
we gonna Paramount we shoot down a
[ __ ] Batman and there's the black
agent and Jeff my manager who's a
barracuda okay we go into the office
they talk to us the visitor that we're
gonna type up the contracts beautiful I
walk out of that room while I'm seeing
his coke rocks and
oh I'm Selig and women that look like
you that's all I'm saying with his
flying women getting fingered sucking
dick even ass the whole thing
nice 27/5 thats that means right off the
bag and doing this 35,000 now I'm
getting about 40,000 it's all said and
done I'm [ __ ] him walking out of that
room and I'll send the black agent turns
around looks like a little Jewish she
goes hey I think you're undercutting my
client no oh my god talking about his
yard that cut my client my client should
be getting 25 for the [ __ ] pilot and
35 for the [ __ ] episode and I'm
looking at her and my insides are
falling apart and she's like well hardly
aged for the other manager you already
was supposed to negotiate the deal what
the [ __ ] so I'm going back in there just
to let you know that's that's I'll
report you I'm a bubble Wow what did you
do tackle Delambre [ __ ] come on my ass I
know what to say oh my god I know you
know but wearing it wearing it one time
I you know me guys I don't I don't even
like saying this type of [ __ ] I'm gonna
put through this way
she talked I'm not gonna give you the
number like I was flat broke living in
Seattle and CBS came to me and I called
my friend and he told me to call her so
I called around for two days first to
see if real agent would sign me and it
was like [ __ ] now we don't give a [ __ ]
who you always send everybody credits
semi-finalists in the Seattle probably
right and then like take that fax to
shove up your ass nobody wants to sign
you chubby and I [ __ ] she signed me
yeah yeah those what a CBS want to give
you and I go I didn't ask I don't even
know what they give you I'll even know
what they're supposed to give you a unit
she does he run you I know I'm what I'm
nine use effect she goes have you ever
acted before I know I did a college film
that one Boulder Colorado film it's just
shut the fire
yeah but it was the festival she's like
shut the [ __ ] up with a college film and
I go she goes have you ever done
anything before like oh no I did
industrial to see how and she was okay
she goes let me call you back
did she calls me back and I'm not gonna
tell you the number cuz I'm embarrassed
I was living in Seattle I was living in
a [ __ ] office I was living and you
know I had a car that blew up his [ __ ]
and just [ __ ] called me and she goes
listen there's what they want to offer
you well she was you have a fax oh yeah
my office she faxes me the [ __ ] offer
and it was peanuts and she goes that's
what they wanted to pay what do you
think I go I don't know I'll get all the
way down there from Seattle yeah okay
give me an ow and the dumb but she came
back with compared to the offer MBC that
I saw on the paper
yeah was just I was like how did you do
that he said that's what I do
yeah sure was done and she goes I meant
this is she was black as soon as I make
[ __ ] money she got them to move me
yeah no way no furniture had none had a
[ __ ] duffel bag this is for a
different show not for the game show no
no this is for different shots of me oh
yeah my bad to the bone she was yeah she
wasn't a movie show you so when she said
she was gonna try to get you more money
you on the inside she did it buddy more
money more more blood no so now that
both fight he's like what do you want to
do and he's like well if you do this
it's gonna be hard for me to work with
you and I go dog it's not like she's
talking on a line yeah yeah I get it you
know it's not like she's talking outta
line yeah and then she went back for
more money and then they came but she
got me like she bumped him from 15 on
the pilot to 20 to 5 nice job yeah and
then what they were doing was putting
final touches on it and making calls and
one day as he called me she goes
at all one away oh it's so hard
wait until they get into an argument in
front of you over money and the age of
this young girl at the because the agent
negotiates yeah the manager guide your
career he talks to you about your next
move what you want to do is just all
[ __ ] you know they don't tell your
[ __ ] they don't talk to you they don't
call you back it's so heartbreaking
though that happened to me with a show
on vh1 that I was like I went and test
shop for it and everything and made the
pilot everything and they were like it's
gonna go through and it was not a ton of
money but more than what I was making
for my playboy show and I was so sure I
was gonna get it everyone loved me and
then right before it was supposed to
start shooting they were like yeah they
decided not to even make it I mean they
just decided to scrap the whole show and
I was like [ __ ] no one understands how
often that happen we're trying to get
Rudy on for next week Rudy Sarzo my
musician buddy because I watched a
documentary and Lee he's not a music guy
you should watch how you I'm tellin I
want it it's called hired good what's
that about music agent it's about hired
guns get hired to join a band for a
salary and what happens then and what
happens in their career is an
interesting oh yeah you know they they
get money for some of them we have money
for writing some of them don't get dick
that sounds great actually where's that
on it's on Netflix on Netflix and they
talk about you know they talk about not
Bruce Springsteen but the other guy
Billy Joel he's one of his band with
these three guys and he did all these
tours that come in one day
he's doing this nude tour and totally
got to really got hurt or the guys don't
get called
it's what is fascinating yeah and Billy
Joel never even called him against the
name he doesn't need he could hire
anybody in the band one of the guys
killed themselves oh and then Buddy
DeVito the drummer and one I then one
day buddy to be there was on for divorce
and one of the Billy Joel he goes hey
man can you give me some extra money
Billy Joe told my hand oh and NOSSA and
he wasn't on the plane with him no more
yeah
recently that's nuts when you're that
rich and that greedy though here we go
he just got robbed by his management
going dollars so though he put a [ __ ]
seatbelt on everything cuz I just
seatbelt on everything if I had money I
would pay for all my friends to do
everything you know what I mean I really
would like my good friends like my
friends that have been around like I
would never let them pick up a check
ever I just feel like once you have it
so many people struggle it was an
interesting episode of The Sopranos
where Christopher gets pissed off
because he has to pick up checks
he's the low man on the totem pole and
he keeps us to pick up checks these
ain't Olalla checks yeah two dollars for
a bishop all day seventeen years
no no no this is [ __ ] Morton's mourns
six guerrillas Goldie like that you pick
Morton's by the way is expensive that's
what they went to a steak house many
went to Atlantic City yeah
any episode and he goes 12 he goes and
Christopher those are the Tony goes amen
what the [ __ ] I'm pissed because I can't
keep picking up these tabs and gonna be
[ __ ] talking about any [ __ ] tabs I
picked up and [ __ ] you he goes Pina
Lugar's with Fat Tony someone and all
those guys I wanted cigars and [ __ ]
wines and so you listen what are you mad
about some day some kids gonna buy you
[ __ ] get it and let me tell you
something for years you know when you
own the road with Joe Rogan that
[ __ ] doesn't play like that dude
just does not play like he goes to
[ __ ] Morton's we'd all like we was so
generous that he's very generous iam tip
100 bucks a drink sometime oh yeah and
you [ __ ] uh you have to do that I've
gone with layout pick up a tab you know
we'll try not come not even you know
whatever the road whatever the [ __ ] what
are you doing we're looking at you like
a [ __ ] change go get me a drink buy
my drink sleep please look at that [ __ ]
from behind oh Jesus Christ when I do
the smell of
like the smell of [ __ ] my mind I
asked you something this is this is
unrelated but I was thinking about you
talking your first year in Hollywood
because you're a guy obviously and I'm a
woman I'm curious like my first couple
years in Hollywood probably first two
years I went to so many meetings and
auditions that now in hindsight I'm like
oh that guy definitely just wanted to be
in a room alone with me for hours or you
know I went on audition I want our
auditions for you I went to okay listen
this is what I mean
I wonder if this happens to guys or if
it's only women cuz when I was new in
town I would go to any audition you know
how it is you'll say yes to anything
right
I had this audition one day for a short
film and the kid was like he'd won like
two awards for like other short films he
made I'm like he was young but maybe
he's like the next Steven Spielberg who
the [ __ ] knows I'll go so I go to this
house and I show up in the kids like so
the senior in is you're playing the
girlfriend of the father and you sneak
in the house late at night to have sex
with this guy and his sons in the next
room over I play the sign and I'm gonna
hear you guys [ __ ] so we won't see
you [ __ ] but we'll hear the sex
noises and then we'll show you sneaking
back out and then you run into me in the
hallway I'm like okay cool so we're
gonna run the dialogue in the hallway
he's like well first I want to get just
your sex sounds on camera just because
that's gonna be you know we need you to
make realistic sex sounds
mind you I'm like 2223 is my first year
here and in my head I'm like this seems
like not real like why would he need my
sex noises on camera but then I'm like
this kid has won awards so I should
probably I shouldn't stretch on this I
was so stupid I got it off like actors
access how [ __ ] thing so I'm like okay
do you really need the video can we just
record the audio and he's like well you
know we're them we're gonna run the line
so we'll just tape the whole thing so
some kids somewhere this kid had to be
21 by the way and him in a mansion in
Westwood probably like his parents own
this place and he's doing this for fun i
sat there and faked an orgasm like When
Harry Met Sally style on camera for the
skit and then I did the whole thing
leave your clothes under it yeah totally
have my clothes I'm just sitting on a
couch slate my name fake the orgasm then
afterwards I go okay so um now are you
ready to run the hallway scene and he
was like you know actually I don't think
it's gonna work out like my fake orgasm
wasn't good enough so I had to leave and
I didn't get to run the lines and I got
in my car and I cried and I was crying
partly because I knew I didn't do a good
job but then at the time I was also like
married and I was like so green and I
also cried because I felt guilty like I
was like oh my god this probably wasn't
a real audition what if I just like kind
of audition for like porno and I started
crying and I called my husband and told
him and he was like horrified like I
can't this is why you should come back
to the Midwest you shouldn't be out
there he wasn't even here with me so
some kid somewhere has a tape of me
where I'm 22 fake orgasm and he's
already walked off thousand people like
some Chinese and that [ __ ] happens here
all the time I mean I can't believe when
you were saying that story what son you
know what Hollywood high is you know
what Hollywood high school yeah yeah
yeah well isn't it like Hollywood
inhaling yeah near the sunset no yeah
yeah yeah yeah sunset in Ireland hold on
one second okay if you think of going
east there's a little mall in there
there's a little mall in there they they
I used to have a Buffalo Wild Wings
Starbucks there's a Burger King and it's
across the street I know what you're
talking about there are still Starbucks
well that little more than that in the
bottom bottom floor there was a little
[ __ ] theater I don't know what it was
called but it was a [ __ ] dive and I
had gone there to do something else I'm
one that said theater and that was the
type of guy in those days there was a
girl that lived in town remember she
used to book the sushi joint on Cahuenga
Yi tents
rue broody Ruby on Cahuenga
Ruby of Kauai in Hollywood Boulevard you
walk 50 yards and they used to be a
Japanese restaurant it was booked by
this girl and it was the coolest place
huh on Tuesday nights it was the coolest
place and I lived around the corner so
what I was trying to do was to get Tommy
more in the area like the I always doing
comedy stand-up on Fridays at midnight
she Ruby did it on Tuesday nights I
think in the place would back up with
agency [ __ ] oh wow yeah because there's
food and everything I should to do yeah
it's different locations they won't go
to the inn problem those places know
what's too easy for they'll go down
there but the her talent that's so weird
that they would be like a sushi bar Shah
oh my god it was a sushi bar like a
Japanese type bomb but you'd have to be
Japanese hang out there that pool table
for shrit and the comedy was great I
think David still has tapes but I'd tape
from there like yeah like for 20 minutes
to plan YouTube yeah but what the [ __ ]
was the point of the story hey Liam
you're talking about weird auditions
like that okay I get a call one day and
they're like listen man some people want
to see you for a movie I don't know [ __ ]
I'm all excited and I know other people
know you know theater over I'm finding
them like I don't say that and they're
like then doing a movie thing other
producers they know a bunch of people I
gotta get into festivals and they're
gonna finance and you're perfect for
little roles
I go okay but at that time I had the fat
ball in my neck yeah and I was just
about to get surgery he's had a fat back
it was all cocaine you're not serious
I'm dead serious it wasn't rate was like
a [ __ ] ball of fat
it wasn't cancerous that was in my neck
and whenever my heart would beat the
ball would go like this it would go up
and no oh you have no [ __ ] idea okay
you're freaking me out so bad so they
had a cut right here Rogen's taught me
to go wrong boys you gotta go get that
taken care
did they biopsy oh and they took it out
of my nose cocaine in it no but
- they showed it to me and that's what
it look like it was like a Google oh it
was like a big ball of cut that been
cleaned away from the cocaine yeah and
kept going through this nostril and it
just developed by my neck Oviatt I
thought there was actual blow in it like
they cut it open it was just all your
blow caught there so I go for the first
[ __ ] odd day this time I had the
movies and [ __ ] like I had done a lot of
[ __ ] and I go for my first audition
listen it was when they called there was
a big feature and bla bla bla bla bla
bla and Sonny Reds gonna be in it this
guy's gonna be in it and then when you
cleared the smoke it was $50 a day ultra
ultra low budget and my role was 9 days
full days and I'm sitting there I go
what are you gonna read well do I got to
lose by reading you don't when went down
and read you don't think I said to me
what you know listen I want you to make
believe this didn't happen
shut up yeah but it was the Mafia's
wanna make believe this is it happened
I'm gonna come home and come back in two
days and do the read that's that bit
that you could do this a lot better
you're cutting yourself short he had two
idiots in a room with him with little
[ __ ] hats like there were like
[ __ ] Sterling's like professional
actors and I looked them we got to know
what to say I didn't want to start a
fight with the guy come on I know you
know what man
I'll come back in two days if you think
that really wasn't me and that really
was a man I couldn't do coke and I had
to do coke because I had the surgery I
was gonna have the surgery about that
time so I was going crazy inside I'm
trying to focus on [ __ ] sides
especially with $50 if you want to call
me in for $50 I'm like I'm going to read
the size in the room will then get at
least there was a real project they were
making
pretend like you just did it for not
this person socially you know what the
movie was a boxer in a Brooklyn
neighborhood goes uh you know God the
Mafia wants and this has been done
already
it was my web boy 3 the boxer no I'm
some mobster this is not gonna win an
Academy Award there's a bit Donna ray it
was no big [ __ ] deal and the next
thing you know he calls me I go down
there and I bang it on and he goes bro
you have to read again for the investors
[Applause]
[ __ ] the family being $80 if you don't
understand your role is a significant
[ __ ] role in the movie oh my god just
gonna knock it out people have loved you
at first Wolvie know why some people go
crazy now oh my god this is why everyone
all I'm thinking about is 50 [ __ ]
dollars if this was a real movie I
wouldn't begin 50 [ __ ] dollars a day
effect he goes I'll call you and we'll
let you know the date when you come in
so guess what it's 9 o'clock at night
this [ __ ] calls me I'm supposed
to get up and go to surgery I'm supposed
to get up a glove what during the
morning and being seen a sign out by six
and this [ __ ] is telling me your
audition tomorrow is that 5:00 in the
afternoon
and I go I got bad news for your brother
you told me you wouldn't call me in a
few days that was a week ago I'm going
into surgery tomorrow he goes well if
you want this role you should come in
here oh my god you know what let me tell
you how I feel the more than four
surgeon let you know I'm sorry didn't
work out because I can't believe you're
doing this to me
you will atop you were the top choice oh
I think you always all of all these
stars and I'm sitting there going where
they say we're saying oh let's run into
your little Clubhouse
this place was a theater that's at 60 if
they were in the back there was like a
shed the backyard if you go there now
all it could be is like a [ __ ] closet
the [ __ ] broom oh my god so he said
you don't understand we have big money
we have wiseguy money in this okay so I
get my surgery listen to me that was
[ __ ] up I've told this before but I
don't know word guess what might come
out of [ __ ] surgery I got the dish of
a hand
shut up call back a producer session for
Hannah Montana
I would've and dimes and I would rub to
those are dishes they were right around
the quad on my house plus I want to be
on Hannah Montana Nickelodeon that's one
of those right there son since you are
Nickelodeon is just hilarious
well the nickel only does background
checks but I passed it so they're
looking for [ __ ] pedophiles not coke
dealers that's why they look at my
resume I got a bunch of Disney X oh yeah
right that one time I went in and I left
there going that was a great read but
you do a background check you have to
sign the waiver right there because my
baloney in court so it makes sense you
gotta sign the waiver on the way home
I'm not gonna get that wrong and instead
he called up Joey these three episodes
what I said watch you on YouTube who's
ever done that's hilarious
I don't even let me on the lot there are
you ready for this yeah this is my point
of this story this is the juice so I get
out of the [ __ ] thing and they're
like you know do you have no cuz holla
yeah because you have that all audition
like how are you feeling I know Doug I'm
not gonna make that audition in as well
we got a producer session for you at
3:30 no I had like one no I'm getting
how the house was about eleven I stopped
at the weed store I already popped to
[ __ ] vicodins and I stopped on my
buddies and got a half an Eightball yeah
flowering right home and then two or
three lines after surgery oh my god
that's what I was Jesus a Christ how is
crazy
you could die I waited for about an hour
and I go let me see let me see how I
feel and I've decided what I want to
know these auditions [ __ ] I'm on dad
I'm ready for them $1,000 and [ __ ] the
other guy the Mafia guy so I was
supposed to go for the Mafia guy at 5:30
I said you know what I'm okay I went
over with this patch on my neck with
blood coming out of it guy and be with a
sweater up to here I did the surgery in
January and I walk in there like all
thank
you for coming I went to Hannah Montana
first and I thank you for coming
you know you're great what time was the
surgery and I'm [ __ ] up on the [ __ ]
vicodin someone at all yeah like in an
envelope - I did like three lines but in
those days that was nothing for me yeah
that was like me this bar and I said
yeah there was nothing three lines or
just for me to get the flavor for it to
calm me down to calm down yeah so I'm
gonna Hannah Montana first and I [ __ ]
read and then I get in the car and I
Drive the Highland Ollie was two blocks
down three blocks down I park and I go
in there early and I go in there to a
room fill the cake wait wish one
better-looking stupid boy that's times
brunettes blondes blacks bunch of pretty
[ __ ] girls yeah yeah because that was
early mmm so I walk in I tell the guy
he's like hey Joey I need old Justin eat
[ __ ] he's totally Italian and they don't
listen bro I just had this urge I'm
[ __ ] up I came in here because the guy
won't see me he goes can you give us
like 15 minutes like okay so I go over
to the side I'm starting to get the
effects of a Viking his [ __ ] and also he
looks at the girl the guy comes up next
like this girl walks out and she's
walking there like a chief surrett like
something had happened
Oh God okay it was Harvey Weinstein's on
no no no no no the guy walks on a hike
8i Nikola you know like one of those
French thing to make you think that he's
cool and you're like I feel so warm and
then he looked at the girl I was maybe
seven feet away it was a small place and
he goes you do know this scene is a type
of scene and you have no problem with
drugs and he's like I didn't read the
whole script at that no problem with
drug drugs okay and
she goes no no you could do drugs on me
they don't think cuz the scene that
won't learn you for it's a big drug
scene this is the party night so you
have to be topless oh my god uh-huh and
then he looks at videos did you but do
you mind if a guy does cocaine off one
of your breasts and this girl and I'm
sitting there going towards like take me
home stick I'm sitting there going honey
here's what I tend to you can measure
your [ __ ] uncle yeah I said you never
showed that monkey until the end
he'll know yeah that's the ace that's
the ace that's the ace I agree but you
don't see them yeah that's more 5000 and
I'm looking to go going you want to say
something dodo it's a small 50 she's
young and new in time just well 50
that's it so I sat then I watched three
girls no way then all three of Michael
yeah we know it's a top st. this movie's
gonna be huge I'm like oh no no we're
going in there and [ __ ] dying like I
was so high yeah they're like well he
just had surgery thank you for coming
down
then they call me and they gave me the
dates and I [ __ ] said listen bro I am
so sorry but my manager called me with
some I got 11 days on the movie when
your shame is like all my [ __ ] god I
had a fight to get you you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] they wanted James Caan close
[ __ ] but I'm gonna go with you that I
believe in you know I saw you the
longest shot how meny listen bro I gotta
go so I get off the phone and the next
day that night I got a call this is guy
Tony something Tony Russo he was in
splash he was the big Italian guy in
splash nobody is he had a great resume I
don't even know he died he died like
three years ago he called me and then he
goes Joey did you tell those people to
go [ __ ] themselves because they call me
with the RO
well I'm thinking what happened James
Caan Yeah right exactly so yeah ever and
we talked for a little while ago how is
he gonna grow I don't know about this I
think I made a mistake is that why you
didn't do when I go yeah it's a mistake
why would anyone do it for $50 and this
guy was
real this guy had done big movies he had
just saved it somewhere Brad Pitt I mean
this guy was the real deal he had been
out here since 83 and he booked splash
with with Tom Hanks why would he say yes
because he gave me the work work those
old-timers Bement Ali's worthless but I
used to do all that work with Dean Cain
Dean came works for ten days four hours
a day
then he'll work for another ten days on
the movie for $150 a day plus a producer
credit so he makes money on the back end
but then he'll go for four days and work
on the movie that pays them yes this
works
oh no he just works yeah that's what
real actor does and their mind they take
everything if it's a role they could do
something with whether it's crazy so you
know I talked to him about a week later
he called me he goes hey bro you got a
crystal ball and I know why he goes oh
my god he goes it was a horror show and
they were cheaper than [ __ ] he goes what
they have no water no I wouldn't give up
water so to really act as quayle it's
crazy that you went on the audition so
high the guy but I wasn't by that but I
won the addition to cocaine wasn't even
in my system
the pills was trying to kick him by
story that I was still high from the
amnesia that's what I'm saying like I
hopes down like I did the surgery seven
ten I was out of surgery three maybe
four hours and I'm walking around that's
what I love about you is you were so
hungry even then like you'd already done
[ __ ] I mean you'd well they make it are
so [ __ ] hungry do you know that after
you know I got my left boob done three
times have I ever told you this story no
yeah so I got my boobs on I talked about
this on stage but I never talked about
it seriously I had so many hold up hold
on what let me tell you what really
happened so I go Russo why was it so bad
he goes besides he was I'm a dad two
daughters never said you have no idea
what they were doing it to the girls I
thought what happened he cuz there's a
scene with the party scene that I told
you he knows he had all these young
girls topless cameras everywhere and
he's young man come on
girls this movie's gonna be billion The
Sopranos this is the real deal shake
those tits
let them snort coke off your tits let
them grab your tits squeeze those
[ __ ] pennies squeeze them you [ __ ]
[ __ ] doing this for his own personal
no was the movie never got it of course
not nothing ever happened with this
[ __ ] movie nothing nothing I'm
nothing no screen because I kept in
touch with him I'd see him on auditions
and busted how was that [ __ ] movie
you look bro I never even heard from
those people yeah that movie never got
finished that movie never got done I've
gotten hired on stuff like that and I
just walk off the minute I start to see
it turned shady I just walk off that's
why I can't relate to a lot of these
women now that are coming out like I did
five movies with this guy who harassed
me I'm like I don't understand that
because as soon as I see any sign of
that I just leave literally just leave I
fat guys where I have a meeting in a
hotel lobby and then the guys like we're
gonna do this in my room and I'm like no
we're [ __ ] not why would we do this
in your room and I just walk away but I
had when I got my boobs done that's I
was gonna tell you when I got my boob
sign I had to have one are you okay yeah
okay I had to have one redone three
times I can't believe you didn't know
this cuz I had like scar tissue it was
building up in the left boob so I kept
having to get it redone and I hired like
a Beverly Hills surgeon so the first
time I got it redone I paid for it the
second time I told him I have my show on
Playboy channel a time and he tried to
charge me full price again and I was
like if you want me to pay for this I
will but on my show I'm gonna talk about
it and I'm gonna say your name and I'm
gonna talk about like how I keep having
to get my boob redone and how it's been
botched by this doctor and I thought
like Asians were the best surgeons but
you're doing a horrible job so he redid
it for me for free that time right but
here's the thing after the third time I
had a blood bag have you ever had
surgery where you had to have a blood
bag like a drainage bag yeah wouldn't
have the surgery I didn't know I was
gonna have it it was like the word blood
bag dude I had a [ __ ] tube a drain
tube coming from my boob out
armpit with a sack hanging off of it
that I had to empty twice a day that
would fill up with pus and blood okay
but wait I know you don't like blood but
this is a story the story has a point
okay did blood [ __ ] up and by the way
it was supposed to only be there for a
week and then they were gonna take it
off me and then for some reason I just
kept draining too much they can't take
it off you until you're drinking less
than some certain amount of day like two
ounces or whatever and I was filling the
bag still like two weeks later and the
doctor was like we don't understand
what's happening but we can't take it
out so for like two weeks I'm walking
around with the [ __ ] blood I had to
hide it but a blood sac okay so I can't
shower myself I didn't want to cancel my
spots I was doing stand-up this is only
like five four years ago maybe so I
didn't want to cancel my spots so I was
going on stage like the Hollywood improv
like the Comedy Store no one knew with
this sack of blood hanging out of my
armpit performing I couldn't gesture
with my left arm at all and then I had
no boyfriend and I couldn't shower
myself so I called my ex-boyfriend and I
asked him to come over and help me like
shower every couple nights and this is
when I learned that men are like
absolute fiends for sex because he came
over I'm so gross I haven't showered in
days that's how we won I'm sweaty
hopeless thank you I have a sack of pus
oh yeah what do you do if you would if
you had seen like a girl and you took
the shirt off and those are blood yeah
you don't know like a locksmith you
understand if I think you're sure though
I see a puss blood side I'm gonna punch
you like TJ Miller you just got me out
like the [ __ ] mouth
TJ I love you um I love you too so this
so my ex at the time he starts to like
and I have bandages over my boobs still
stitches in one boob and then my ex he's
like cleaning me off I smell and then he
goes is it weird that this is turning me
on
yeah and I was like yeah I'm [ __ ]
disgusting I got pus bag hanging off me
and he was like can I [ __ ] you and then
I didn't even want to but I felt like I
owed him because he's taking care of me
so I was like I guess so I wasn't
reserved sex for a month so I was like
you can but you got to be slow you can't
you can't raise my heart rate or the
stitches my bust me was like four day
dirty hair and a puss bag hanging out
and I was smelly and gross and shaved oh
and um he enjoyed it though I think so
Tommy he took that condom office lift it
for a month that was he smell like
[ __ ] that's when I learned cuz you
know how girls are always like like when
I go out if I don't want to [ __ ] a guy I
don't shave my legs I'm like there's no
way I'll [ __ ] with hairy legs as if
like that's gonna stop any man we don't
give a [ __ ] what times a man on the most
dirty when you're right nope what if
your man hasn't given us time and all we
get to ladies write this down for uncle
Joey
oh god I'm afraid only better and wake
up next morning in quality time you got
the flu and moan and groan nothing turns
a man on then when you're sick a woman
I'm telling you soon as your wife tells
you she's a little sick you want to give
her a little kick to it why because
there's something about a sick woman it
was an exactly
she always like walking through the
cancer ward of the hospital just with a
hard boner
you're now dead chemo pills
charity he does really turns me on the
most when a guys really really really
really mad at me when he's so mad at me
he wants to kill me that's what I want
to [ __ ] the most I love to like I love
when a guy's so mad at me never wants to
see me again so I know on the inside he
wants to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of me and
that's when I want him to do it the most
like punishment boulier to tell you all
these rules that came with you pull a
hair is showing your wrist a band all
this this is Kato [ __ ] you leave you
take Kate home till you got a punch in
the neck yeah just wrote a jab right
like a stiff [ __ ] hole badge at what
point during this XD throw the jab is it
like right I don't know as an opener no
you go back to add a little holiday in
over there across the street yeah and
when she closes the door she's gonna
have to go to the bathroom right so she
comes on the bathroom before you I'm
hiding right there drinking your left
hand throw the drink in her face
open-hand slap punch no pun you don't
condone punch it then you throw the
drink on a face and go tell her go make
me another drink
oh my god do a Dustin Hoffman rub my
feet dudes and I'm in the mood for a
foot rub and the best about the movie
all these all these stories that are
coming out like a lot of them are bad I
don't want to get I can't argue that I
mean I don't want to get punched by a
guy coming out of a bathroom but but I'm
not gonna lie like oh god I'm afraid to
say this this is why your podcast freaks
me out because I get so buzzed I tell
the whole truth but when i when i read
TJ's story this morning you masturbate
the first thing I thought it said it
said the girl said he choked me out I've
kind of want to [ __ ] now that's a
party
consensually but I'm right there I know
it's in love with you choke them and
[ __ ] popular your dick and I used to
have a girl that poker game what are you
talking about it's the [ __ ] of is your
finger yeah okay okay
yes I have a question now so I haven't
been single for a while but you don't
say right you've been off the market
she's mad at you for three [ __ ] yeah
I know man
you brought some [ __ ] I say I heard
about your huge [ __ ] too
so he told me is a savage I know where
are you that well he said that he heard
and I don't I don't go on men dates you
don't say locker room
no but I don't look at that I look
straight ahead be the prisoner your dick
come on
I want the prison is he one day you have
to see we still a doctor there's no way
you've never seen a dick all right fine
I saw my stepfather's dick when I was
like eight explains a lot and I watch
for the dick comes on I go it's
uncomfortable you know what I said
I send guys like porn tapes of me
[ __ ] but I I do POV from my angles so
they only see the man I don't want to
see that at all
that's all my porn collection it's just
me [ __ ] holding a camera and it's
just the guy guys love it no I don't
question okay and I don't even like the
choking of the smacking thing but let's
say I did in this like world we live in
today like how do you you can't just go
for it
because the like what if the girls like
it's so funny you're saying that cuz I
was just saying to my friend the other
day I was like I really want to shoot a
sketch where a guy and a girl start to
have sex and then like every step of the
way like some lawyer pops out of a side
room of the contract to like have the
girl sign and notate like each and like
it's okay to [ __ ] me but if you touch my
[ __ ] then that's like it's just guys
now are afraid like listen to you you're
like what if I choke her and then that's
too far like you're actually afraid it
was a girl wolf
Jason I never even heard of children
somebody well I never heard of none of
these things I was like really naive
when it came to that until what if I
started dating a [ __ ] lunatic and you
start dating a couple I became a comic I
started dating women define lunatic Joey
lunatics just me women outside the norm
that you
and after two weeks you know that you
like him you're in love with them but
this ain't gonna go no way she's too far
I can't bring this [ __ ] home she's
crazy and she'll [ __ ] my grandfather by
mistake my grandfather's dead she'll
suck his dick you just know you just
know it's not a trust thing and they're
just lunatics this is gonna be I mean I
hope you always you always go I am
optimistic maybe but this she's [ __ ]
nuts so I met a bunch of women like that
in a row that just illuminated me to the
world of choking and smacked me in the
face and I'm never the first time like a
girl asked you to choke her everything
everything I've ever done is because
somebody asked me she never had the
impulse to just naturally knock somebody
out
no but like choke him a little or be
like really like I mean I just didn't
like it interesting some guys don't if
you have you cooked me up and drink me
up at 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning when
I'm trying to get my dick hard and [ __ ]
I'll have to throw a couple left hooks a
you don't smack to the face like smacks
to the face open-handed I think we took
this girl close to four years for me to
hit her how she wanted me you're only
supposed to smack to like slap a girl
the way like your parents spank you and
your kid like you didn't really want to
it wasn't that hard but they did it I
knew they still wanted me to [ __ ]
smack her hard yet like in the cheek
it's like [ __ ] Baba like I would take
my dick out of a mountain just be hit
her in the face like a [ __ ] bullet
bouncing off her face face is like one
boxer I loved it I was shoveling and
pulling out of a [ __ ] knife and tell
her you like that dick you [ __ ] and
twist the head like this noise this all
twisted like yeah she was that's what
she wanted though I did not know that
existed I don't like to have to ask for
it though that's the thing like if I
have to ask for it here's the problem
the guys that do it naturally that just
like wanna do it they wanna like choke
the [ __ ] out of you and they're like
angry at women those aren't usually good
men to date and the guys you have to ask
they never do it like they really want
to and you know it so it doesn't really
work I could do it if I'm lunatic Lee
coked-up they don't choke your wife no
are you [ __ ] crazy
I don't know no no lady you never choke
her oh she kill me but here I have no
like that's a thing like who I have no
interest in choking anybody all right
let's say I try it
what's that took a girl home thank you I
take a home we'd do some coke we talk a
little bit and then the [ __ ] shirt
will come off I'd suck your titties okay
take the pants off a little [ __ ]
stupid anything I will leave you [ __ ]
you know put my dick in your mouth [ __ ]
yeah
eat your ass and then I got I flip you
over leave your ass I would I would I
would machine on your ass with my tongue
Oh grab you with two finger Louie and
scrape the bottom of your [ __ ] so go
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] and with you
don't and then if that doesn't drive
them to say just put it in my ass you
have to be a gentleman and you're second
I'm gonna stick it in your ass if she
goes no no no I would never popular your
ass just because it was sticking that I
would always lick it manipulate it I
would always at least work that [ __ ] to
where you go you drive me crazy with
those gorilla fingers pop that [ __ ]
Cuban I grill in my [ __ ]
but if you don't say it I'm gonna just
skull chain my dick in your ass and you
know you're not and that's where it ends
and I'll put it back in the broad think
my fingers out and slam family touchy
topic there's a Christmas special I'm
gonna make it
this is a disclaimer to say that I'm not
condoning this for other women but like
I was so scared to take it in in the
butt you know I've only done it was one
guy because of you because you said no
one take me a dinner ever again but I
was really scared so I kept telling that
guy no also I was trying to save it for
love like I really wanted to save it for
like my next husband
but this guy you know he kept kind of
trying and every time you try a little
more and I'd say no it's up I didn't try
a little more and it's you know I need
to stop and then one night I was like I
don't want to I don't want to and he was
like let me just try and it's like I
don't want to I don't want to and then
before I knew it was in there oh yeah I
already busted your hymen yellow
rubberband what I'm saying place the
rubberband inside it but you should
never say you should never you should
never do it when the girls saying no he
shouldn't have done that but then once
it was in there I was like oh it's not
that bad and then it was kind of nice so
now I'm like I should be mad at him for
doing that but in some ways I'm kind of
like glad but you but he was very
careful and I never knew I was like I
could slip in your ass if you were coked
up and we'll [ __ ] up with 6:00 7:00 in
the morning and I can tell I have you
halfway there why the morning halfway
there I got two fingers in your [ __ ]
okay and I got my middle finger in your
[ __ ] and I'm looking around like a
popsicle
and I'm finger-banging your [ __ ] in
your [ __ ] at the same time and you
listen right you but you pop in that ass
if you can't it's always happening and
then you take those two fingers out and
just chew and then clip for a little
while like no on it like a dog [ __ ]
drown yourself and I'll do that 35:35
okay
that's 15 years of dick and that [ __ ]
Clinton we think happens to get softer
it gets tougher like during my marriage
there wasn't a whole lot for you caught
on you made time for Connor so the clip
gets tougher like that coconut oil on it
every day that doesn't matter
yeah somebody's gonna come along give
you [ __ ] the Stabbin for like a year
I hope suck all the coconut oil out of
it and waiting happens to you dude it
looks like beef jerky and I can bite it
once you get to bug be about 40 you knew
it was gonna be like beef jerky
[Music]
rejuvenation okay here's what's gonna
happen I'm never gonna get [ __ ] done to
my face I'm just gonna get [ __ ] done to
my [ __ ] so it's like Benjamin Button
vagina that's the plan for my vagina
time I'm 60 I'm gonna have the [ __ ] of
like a 15 year old girl Joey anything
can happen now with chemicals and I'm
gonna chemical peel my vagina oh Jesus
why not Joey said I'm gonna look like
beef jerky what if the surgery goes
wrong how can it go wrong look Joey got
rid of his fat nugget he's fine yeah but
that's Jana's shoulder that was a fat
ball in my shoulder I'd rather die in
surgery than have beef jerky [ __ ] oh my
just a clip I would rather die I by the
time you're 50
you can like do
is to the cliff stop it what drops how
do you it why do they replace the
clothes with something what you tell you
how you toughen up you know you want a
soft quick oh no you want a medium rare
me you wanted in the middle a little
men's a men's men's double okay you are
tough on the outside and I'll bet they a
little [ __ ] soft on the inside
what we you want you to sing the dirtier
quick Krazy Glue yeah you tell me I
don't understand probably gonna do some
shout outs then we'll talk about can we
can I take a bathroom break
yes you can alright well do the shout
out
take your time take your time very up
we're trying to help her out you're like
I'm like a [ __ ] crystal ball what
what wow you're like a Christmas miracle
or something eat this mushroom no okay
all these people way if you need to
miracle to eat the [ __ ] mushroom
which Onkel Joey's and when they either
you leave me it you told me old they go
Nathan
let's get some shoutouts here forget
[ __ ] Lee Johnny Lee Bozza O'Shea
filled roulette boat Ola David Robertson
Josh kitty Lord Rosica my dog Leon Vega
sling his dick and [ __ ] taking
Germans money little pancake be careful
with the [ __ ] animals and my man Dom
De Niro always showing up on the job you
follow me I also want to say Happy
Holidays to everybody who really want to
take a minute to the church family
extended Church family my Australian
family my [ __ ] English family UK you
know Highland listen man I love you more
the [ __ ] thank you for supporting the
Soria and I hope that you know your
[ __ ] Christmas with your families
I just remember sand if you having a
hard time I want you just to [ __ ] and
close your eyes and think about next
Christmas how good it's gonna be you
know everybody has tough Christmases so
uh I hope then motivate you a little bit
not to be down if you're if you're
scared about what Christmas is gonna
feel like you know what it's gonna feel
like any other Christmas Harvey you want
it to fail so go to dinner eat to be
your family no matter what go show up be
a bigger person don't be a mope like I
did fees what do you think [ __ ]
yeah I'm someone who was away from
family for the holidays and you were
very nice and I you always invited me
over for Thanksgiving and and Christmas
and everything and and but there's also
I had asked some of my best times with
people I work with we had potluck dinner
so do stuff like that guys I mean it's
it's tough being alone and if you're if
you are alone you know what goodly I
make the best of movie I'll just say cuz
I used to [ __ ] do the craziest [ __ ]
things when I was single
how'd you buy movie plans $9.99 a month
a movie a day that's it $9.99 a month
you get one ticket to a movie today so
you probably get three for your family
it's great and pays for itself after one
movie after two three and you go to
Laemmle no uh they they go a lot of
places I don't know about the limelight
but maybe what Hollywood dope yeah yeah
the only places that I know that I that
I checked was the thing that they don't
go to uh what was the nice one at
Sherman Oaks
I don't know nasally like a Hollywood or
this one do they have no though that's
white here that's from 95 the people
that go to arc like don't you want to
talk to you Arclight they [ __ ] kill
you going in the [ __ ] chicken sauce
the sandwich though if you ever got an
article in Hollywood I don't know if
they still have it's been years for me
but the chicken sauce is [ __ ]
sandwich
with the country's chicken oh my god
Lisa I would mustard good and onions
delicious whatever you got are you Katie
Dodd dog in the [ __ ] movie thing but
least they tried to lynly they have a
little chicken sauce since he had a
couple things they but they banging out
the aspirin don't get me wrong I mean
you're gonna pay for them sorry I just
got a case of [ __ ] burps I do I do
like the way they're because that day
that we went to see Coco the other day
and I like the there's a couple theatres
aren't here that have really nice for
climbing chairs where's the Regency the
Regency
I bumped into a listener today at the
car wash I went me and my wife went to
wash our cars they were [ __ ] filthy
from Mercy colourings
[ __ ] apples [ __ ] headshot on us
you know I've had shots we call those
things sunglasses I couldn't believe how
much [ __ ] was in both cars over thank
you just so he was saying that I he goes
to the regency theater I think it's in
Burbank it's an old theater well there's
one in Vienna
okay though that's a good one the Van
Nuys plant one it's kind of a little bit
it's really high up in Van Nuys oh wait
it's a movie theater yeah and then
there's one in North Hollywood Valley
Plaza six why are you talking about
movie theater because he bought a
pastime would you got a lot of movies no
really do you I literally only go to
movies when guys take me in that's very
rare it's not that I love movies I'm
just so busy
honestly I hardly ever have a night to
go I see more movies on the road when
I'm by myself
maybe I'll go like in a mall but that's
pretty much it
or I just Netflix stuff I used to watch
more I used to love movies like that's
why I wanted to act cuz I love movies
and then slowly over time I just got
more into stand up and I just hardly
ever go to the movies now I used to go
to our movies all the time I'm in a
movie
god knows how long are you a Star Wars
guy no oh my god
I was telling you this story earlier I
have to tell this because I want to know
what people think cuz I think chicks
will be on my side okay but I'm actual
like still bitter about it I wish I
could say who it is so [ __ ] bad I
dated a cop if you can't say was don't
tell us I kind of want I think maybe
because he said on his podcast that he
[ __ ] me did I ever tell you this story
okay [ __ ] it I'm gonna tell it he's
gonna get so mad but whatever okay so
years ago this is years ago I dated
Bobby Lee years ago right I would never
have said it except Bobby went on his
podcast I'm still mad and he talked
about [ __ ] me I never told a soul
that we hooked up because I don't like
people to know my business but Bobby
went on his podcast and he said that
[ __ ] me was like [ __ ] Michael
Phelps
because I'm so athletic and I was so sad
and then no one knew we [ __ ] and the
way that I found out is someone on my
Instagram people on my Instagram started
calling me like Michael Phelps and I
said I have Michael Phelps ass and asked
if I was like training for the Olympic
swim team and [ __ ] and that's how I
found out that he told this story
well that's the thing is later here did
an apology episode where he apologized
and he said it's a compliment your
athletic whatever but I was pissed that
he told that we [ __ ] so I never would
name him but now I feel like I can't
okay but here's the thing so I know I
love Bobby for the record I really do
he's a [ __ ] and I love his girlfriend
they're both up yeah I love him but so
I'm on my hands too these suck
somebody's dick uh I know that someone
asked him to I don't know if he does
crazy I mean he's a nut he's a [ __ ]
nut but I love it oh my god he's gonna
kill me for this I'm so buzzed okay so
long story short I meet Bobby I
instantly loved him
people said [ __ ] to me like why would
you Bobby Lee I'm like he's so sweet and
he's childlike and he's cool and he's
funny and at the time I just come out of
the most like abusive horrible
relationship and Bobby's like the
complete opposite you know he just was
so like affectionate and just awesome
he's an awesome guy so I liked them and
we started hanging out and he was just
like he was so into me like he drove all
the way to Palm Springs to take me to
lunch one day I was like working a gig
in Palm Springs he just was like so into
me and he would like buy me gifts for no
reason
and he told all my girlfriends like
comic friends like I'm so in love with
your friend Kate she's so amazing so it
didn't even go on that long it's just a
couple months you know a few months I
don't know but one day we're hanging out
and I mentioned I had never seen Star
Wars any of them like I'd seen them
they've been on in the background around
my house my brother's a nerd but like I
never sat down and watched one so Bobby
was like horrified he's like how could
you never have seen that it's just like
a person like a comedian like you need
to see it and I was like well I saw
space balls I like that like to me I got
all the innuendo like I get it he's like
no you have to watch Star Wars so one
day I come over to his place we start
watching Star Wars partway and we kind
of started fooling around then we end up
having sex right so we have sex we watch
the rest the movie after the movie I
wasn't that impressed it wasn't bad
you know I remember thinking Harrison
Ford was really hot but and it wasn't
terrible but I just wasn't that is to it
you know yeah so afterwards he's like
let's go get food so we went to
Greenblatt's we're sitting at
Greenblatt's we eat and I will never
forget it it was the first time ever I
was out with him that he was on his
phone like the whole time he never
looked at his phone we were together he
was just like it was so obviously lost
all interest in me he wasn't talking
he's looking at his phone and then he
was like so without even looking up I
remember he's like so what do you think
of the movie and then I was like you
know it was okay I was really and it was
really my thing that's fine you know and
he was quiet just quiet the whole meal
and then on the way home he was like I'm
dropping him back off I'm driving I'm
dropping him back off at his place and
he's like stop at this gas station we're
gonna get cigarettes I'm gonna get
cigarettes we stop he goes in to buy
smokes he comes back out opens my car
door and he's like you know what I was
gonna walk home it's just a few bucks
but I'll hit you up I'll talk to you
soon and he left and I never saw him
again we never hung out again like every
once in a while I would text him like yo
what's going on are we are we cool did
you
hanging again he'd just be like really
busy really busy and we never hung out
again and then finally one day he said
something like I don't know I just could
never date a girl it doesn't appreciate
Star Wars like it was like Star Wars was
like the end-all be-all
which in hindsight he was right anyway
cuz we never would have we didn't have
enough in common like we really didn't
but like Star Wars was that the the
whole like deal-breaker like that was
such a deal-breaker
there was nothing more humiliating than
you loving a movie as a man Wow there is
nothing wrong I don't know what is I
love this has happened the guys who
listen to the podcast you're in love
with a movie and you want to share it
with the woman of your dreams and she's
not into the movie she goes huh
you might as well tell us you have a
headache the next six months maybe it's
a good test of a relationship if they
don't love it cuz I just thought about
that but was there a movie that you
could show your wife that if she didn't
love it you would have been like it's
over like my favorite movies The Big
Lebowski but if you didn't get it I
wouldn't be like I can never [ __ ] you
again I'd be like that's weird
people say some well [ __ ] I had a woman
say she was only a date you know I was
into the date said she she noticed the
guy was a Democrat so she declined but
he was perfect except for that you know
you get to meet him that's different
that's a whole like belief system well I
mean I got it I got it because in some
ways like my brother is such a big like
Star Trek Star Wars nerd type guy that
he could never date a girl that wasn't
into that cuz it's almost like a
religion like they they would have
nothing in common as a man the woman
didn't listen the best thing was oh I
can't [ __ ] stand I don't [ __ ] with
Lee
I love Lee to death what do you never
usually would do different things he's a
Jew and he's a go-getter
but this is the only Jew I know that
wants to relax he thinks that he does
he's the only Jew I know it gets relax
but they don't he deserves to relax that
the world owes it interacts so it's kind
of funny yeah I appreciate them but like
I don't I would never bother me on a
Sunday because if I go always house and
Lee and Paula have on no English or
charts on I'll finally on the spot what
what wait if I go to Lee's on the Sunday
yeah
Paul I have on the winglet sweatshirt
yeah I'll file the other spot that's
hilarious
oh no no problem because you hate the
Patriots so much why I don't understand
because as a woman I want you to have
your own [ __ ] oh you're saying if they
have a matching shirts oh yeah I hate
that you ever go to a person you ever go
to a family's house and it works vice
versa
he's a fan of Texas she's from [ __ ]
Jersey
well said she knows more about yes yeah
you feel bad you any of this dummy she
joins gonna be like oh my god what we do
if Texas loses you're from Jersey we
give advice I hate when people do that
[ __ ] yeah that for a couple yes I hate
that too I want you to say you know what
I'm watching with him because it makes
him happy but I don't really give a [ __ ]
what happens no I don't even yeah I
don't even like when people put their
couple photo as their someone puts their
couple photo as their profile photo on
social media I'm like oh you just made
yourself into two people like that's so
gross to me like no matter I love my
wife
of course I don't want I wanted to have
a visa saying you're a person this comes
out welcome to women when she's watching
something I'm leaving Jack the TV go
back to my office right now yeah you
gonna smoke pot that's the way around
and I go why them I know what she's done
then I go back in there can I tell you I
like that she gets up yeah I watch
Spanish TV sometimes this she'll sit for
20 minutes and she gets the [ __ ] out of
that she won't tell me to change that
she hates this [ __ ] that's why I watch
it at night
oh my god I hate today literally I can't
say who this is but today I was googling
a friend of mine looking for a photo of
him because I'm gonna have him on my
podcast and his Wikipedia came up and it
was funny cuz I clicked on his ex-wife
he's divorced now I clicked on his
ex-wife so I was surprised she had a
Wikipedia cuz she was just a regular
girl I most people that have Wikipedia
are you know like a public figure so I
clicked on it and she was just listed as
his ex-wife and I was just thinking like
how sad for like you to be a public
figure but you're only your status or
the reason you're known is so and so's
wife like I would never want to be some
guy's girlfriend some guy's wife like I
always feel bad for girls at parties
that are introduces like this is Jessica
so and so's girlfriend like don't you
just want to be Jessica the amazing
publicist or the amazing writer that
whatever like that really bothers me but
my mom is so independent that I have to
be like I can't ever be half of a guy I
have to be my own person than the guys
like whatever he has his [ __ ] going
that's probably why I'm single though
guys hate independent women you don't
George for us you have him on here I
love George look true we're like super
tight homies George always says to me
Kate one day I sent him a photo of me
and a dress because I was trying to pick
out a dress to wear to an event and I
sent him like three dresses I go which
one do you like and he wrote back I like
this one cuz you look like a woman with
no opinions and it's a joke George and I
have where he says guys see you and they
think you have too many opinions because
you're smart so you almost gotta like
have no opinions for a guy to want to be
with you because guys get intimidated by
like women that are their own person
like your wife is a baller
so that must turn you on that she's so
like independent and smart and cool you
like that about her didn't make you run
away yeah but were you always like that
did you always like girls that had their
own [ __ ] going or were you ever one of
those guys that I don't want you around
me 24/7
oh nobody around me 24/7 no I don't want
you whole month my
I don't want you going to certain things
with me I'm the type of guy I need to
breathe [ __ ] ten minutes do you guys
ever disagree on like major issues like
like does your wife kind of have your
same mindset when it comes to like
society politics really shut up yeah
because it's all your fight no not that
we find I just don't want to hear it I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't talk politics
either I don't give a [ __ ] I really
don't want to hear it so if you're gonna
keep talking to me about this I'm
definitely will you i'ma say my try on
the other [ __ ] ear
we talk about [ __ ] I don't talk you know
I don't say nothing to her about [ __ ]
that I know she doesn't want to hear and
you have to know you have to know that I
get not everybody won't say he is [ __ ]
but I really want to hear but your life
tell people just don't what the [ __ ]
going on the Mars landing I know what
the [ __ ] the Martians are [ __ ] maybe
there's a UFO coming down it's just
that's one of the things about a
relationship that I always want to be in
a relationship but I also want to say
I'm independent well it was independent
is you you see other people who was
dependent you don't we come home an
independent is that they think for love
why do you do [ __ ] on Saturday will you
friends yeah have your own life Saturday
night we'll hook up
yeah but Saturday they go do something
Oh German [ __ ] Lake but that's what's
so cool about you do something you can
tell that you like respect well it took
me [ __ ] years
really we we're all jealous you know
we're all jealous so we all over have to
come that obstacle in our manhood you
know every guy is very jealous or they
do think at their base nature out of
that if you have to go somewhere
every salad to a clock I'm gonna ask you
might say so what are you doing your job
uh-huh I meet this whole guy and suck
his dick and it gives me the small 300
now how many women have that job that's
a small that's a select what category
what I'm saying is it just takes levels
you know I failed
marriage the first time when I had
looked back at those failures to see
what the [ __ ] I had done wrong and the
exact you know I would my feelings get
hurt if not if she didn't like the same
movie but if she didn't want talking
about a certain subject you know my
feelings were gonna hurt them Emily
Wynne said one of my feelings getting
hurt
she don't worry about that [ __ ] that's
not a world and she said another world
yeah
why would I impose my world on it she's
my wife she's my girlfriend why might I
give a [ __ ] if she don't like it you
come to me you have to get over that
there's also something to like society
says like your partner supposed to be
your best friend but I actually think
like I talked to my girlfriend's about
[ __ ] that is girlfriend [ __ ] like guys
don't want to talk to you about every
[ __ ] thing that goes on so I try to
reserve I try to feel there's no guy
gives a [ __ ] about your and oklahoma's
foot problem that's what I mean that's
like this I come home or day's work and
you give me a kiss and Wilma beating you
like I tell you about on me first off I
need to take a [ __ ]
my balls are sweating and itchy I just
want to take a [ __ ] jump in the shower
then we're gonna use toilet paper I'm
gonna wash my ass my [ __ ] shower like
a Puerto Rican Baudette stop before I go
in there you're gonna stop me with your
[ __ ] I hope you don't Cheryl do pho
with you tell me about your [ __ ]
about your rant from Oklahoma's foot
hurts and she's got one bago and you
might have to laugh a little [ __ ] I got
[ __ ] on my mind it was a mortgage I read
an article where they were like women
the problem is women want men to be
their best friend but then also be a
[ __ ] savage like we want guys to be
guys but then we're starting to really
low articles don't read I read all the
articles Joey
that's why videos the last relationship
cut it off at six months instead of a
year oh I'm getting I'm getting so much
better yeah
imagine I am I'm telling you read those
magazines and go with your heart
I read it no my heart is wrong because
you let your [ __ ] dominate everything
no I let my brain die over things I
overthink like if he doesn't send me a
kissy emoji I think she hates me Nikolas
took seether one no suck it I'm very
horny
I will admit like super money but you
know I don't [ __ ] that much I've only
had sex with like three guys this year I
know for you guys talk baby
no three guys know if you [ __ ] you an
animal I'm trying to think you talking
while I count the guys thing yeah count
them keep counting no I think you missed
know what is this what is this it's
December it's the 12th one I'm trying to
12 times to 36 I'll pick the over more
I'll pick the over what's it count one
that Lake Joe's 12 is 24 wait do we
carry a month do we count with no that's
36 I'm taking the Overland you're so off
my numbers still under 22 for the whole
life for my whole life
I'll stop hand of the Bible I can still
what wait we're talking about sex right
I don't count a hand job [ __ ] I don't
blow guys that I don't have sex with
very often once a dick comes out it's
over I don't believe in vases its first
a homerun for me but until I'm sure I
don't [ __ ] them unless I know it's gonna
be one time and I've only done that
twice
all right side the 10 two times a month
times 12 is 24 guys the year started I
still was following four guys a year
plus you slip a couple days couple Terry
job grabs Terry Crews Jeb's
I did not assault Terry Crews so the
omen on this 21 and a half I think it's
only like 20 to life time I'm telling
you I'm gonna count you keep talking
about politics Alton me 22 lifetime I
swear I swear it's not 37 years I can
still name a mall hold on No
we have the moist 30 it's only been 5
and there's only been like four or five
please I swear oh please why here there
was a lot let me ask you a question when
you [ __ ] Bobby Lee oh let me smell
Asia why did I bring this up I'm gonna
kill myself
I smell the tea wasn't that good no stop
Bobby smells great he smells like
essential oil I never said a bad word
about Bona I know except for when he
talked about about five cats only
because I was pissed and I caught him
Bobby got into her I never said [ __ ]
absolutely smells really good I heard
you smell these he said he smelled a
Gucci I never said that ever I don't
even know what that word means you do I
never said about learn about Bobby be
real I never did the only thing I said
was he really this is really what
happened after that all went down
I was with Redman actors hanging out
with Reb band when it started to like
pop no never a fix in the hotel
oh stop robbing I've never done [ __ ]
Brian I've always been friends we've
always been friends
but no I was with Brian when all this
[ __ ] started to come out cuz you know
what else Bobbie said there's this Waka
Flocka video that i did oh my goodness
did you ever see the Waka Flocka video
it went so viral it was on it was
literally on like TMZ I think
Entertainment Tonight it was on
everything and basically it was
backstage the AVN Awards waka flocka was
the performer I didn't know who he was
I'm so white I know nothing like jay-z
could punch me I wouldn't even know he
was jay-z I mean
waka flocka to me it was just a cute
tall rapper guy we met backstage and he
was like let's get a picture and I said
let's do a funny video where you walk
into that hallway and I'll come out and
I'll like torque on you but really bad
like a shitty white girl dance move and
then you just look at me like I'm the
biggest loser you've ever seen and walk
away and we won't tell anyone we're
gonna do it right so we do this I posted
on my Instagram
walk a repost it everyone in the world
thinks it's real
it went so viral it still pops up this
was now like almost two and a half three
years ago it still pops up all the time
on like the most embarrassing moments of
all time on the internet because
everyone thought I was just like a drunk
pathetic fan trying to get his attention
but horrible at dancing and women were
so angry because he's married women were
like they made it into a race war online
people were like this is why black men
get accused of raping white women this
hoe is trying to [ __ ] Walker his wife
was his wife was there and knew we did
it and she was like hella cool but
anyway Bobby on his podcast cuz the
video went so viral he brought it up and
he said that it made me look racist he
didn't know that it was staged
so then red band called Bobby I was like
that [ __ ] was staged you shouldn't talk
[ __ ] about Kate
then Bobby called him and apologized the
next day then he called me and
apologized and then he did like an
apology episode and then I saw him at
the Comedy Store a couple times after
that and he wouldn't talk to me he would
like run away like hey Kate and dart off
like he was afraid she'd do an episode
to apologize for what to tell people is
next no funny
no his next month Bobby smells amazing
he smells like seriously he smells like
like like Chinese oils like he wears
like nice oily I don't know what it is
he smells great and his girlfriend is
stunning as you know but the point is I
I texted him and I said hey when you see
me at the Comedy Store you not to run
away we're cool now I'm over it and give
me a hug and say hi we can be friends
and he texts me back yeah Kate we're
gonna be great friends and then since
then actually when I've seen him he's
been cooler but it's just funny cuz the
whole thing is like way more awkward
than it should be but I guess I this
isn't gonna help this is probably gonna
fuel the awkwardness Bobby I love you if
that's what killed me about mess around
at the Comedy Store because you have to
see these people you have to keep saying
like the comic that's why I try not to
date comics I oh my god because now you
gotta see him
yep
but now it's fine for a long time floor
but I won't lie it's still weird like if
I'm on stage and he walks in the room
I'll at least noticed like it does
change the dynamic when you hook up at
the comic that's why I try so hard not
to the last guy dated was a comic but
when I met him I didn't know he was a
comic really I thought he was just more
of an actor then all of a sudden I was
like oh he's a comic like a real comic
he's like everywhere and then I wanted
to kill myself so life is great what do
you look for 2018 what do you want 28
you know what I just uh I almost want to
jinx it it makes me I always feel we
were talking about things that are like
supposed to happen but I just told them
that I'm working on a book and I got a
good book thing going that I'm really
excited about and I want to bring back
the Hollywood pool party I think I'm
gonna do it with all things comedy or
talking about that and then I have a
couple Oh my podcast date fells is
actually doing awesome I still have to
have you guys on I want to have you guys
on it I haven't had you and I've got
tons of road dates which is awesome like
I'm I'm actually gonna be in Vegas with
Dom I'm with Dom Moreira at the Laugh
Factory December 26 through through New
Year's and then I've got tons of
headlining or days to be in New Jersey
yeah we're doing New Year's Eve at the
Vegas Laugh Factory so funny
yeah yeah it'll be a great time and
actually Jack Jr is there with Adam
hunter playing la comédie clubs so like
we're all gonna party together in Vegas
gonna be awesome so I'll be there all
week and then next year I got lots of
Road dates it's it's nice cuz I'm
getting I'm getting a lot of headlining
dates what do you want to happen in 2018
I mean career-wise
would you like to book a pilot of that
one I almost don't even want to put it
out there because I feel like it's
always it jinx is it to say that loud
though I met jinx Tet jinx have you got
something working you don't want to jinx
no but it drinks this I feel weird like
some I want to get I'll say this I'll
say this I want to get I do
I do it just makes me nervous to say it
but um I wanna there's a show I'm trying
to sell I'd like to shop sell that and
I'm working on this book and I wanna get
the book done I mean they told me the
timeline they gave me it should be done
next year so that would be dope and then
comedy wise I mean I just I just
submitted my half-hour to Comedy Central
so that would be awesome but I'm
thinking about if it doesn't get on
Comedy Central I'm thinking about
putting it on YouTube because I have a
couple bits on there that I think would
do you know it's funny we were talking
about this me and you but it's almost
like in some ways I feel like now the
[ __ ] that goes viral it's almost more
beneficial than having something on a
network like Netflix or HBO like I was
just at Ontario improv I don't know if I
told you this and Angela Johnson was
coming up and they were telling me that
Anthony Jeselnik at a weekend there and
they said he did well with sales but
then they put Angela Johnson's
sales up and they she sold out like two
weekends in like 15 minutes or something
and they said it's all like that viral
that was that one bit so in my mind
there's part of me that's like
everyone's like I want the Comedy
Central half-hour the Netflix special
but part of me is like I have a couple
bits I'm like let me play some to you
just because Comedy Central or Netflix
does not take you special it does not
mean the end of the world and especially
in today's climate that's what I'm
saying is it is so internet that you
know what okay almost doesn't matter
yeah another Friday night at one time
and no plan against alia midnight yeah
and it goes bye-bye and people have to
look it up and blah blah blah so it's
not all it's cracked up to be
you take that half hour cousin to really
put focus on your YouTube page before
you release that's right until six
months of good focus on your YouTube
page you know what here's the problem I
think your solution what the problem is
I've seen millions of people trying to
shoot that video that goes viral but you
don't know you don't have a big window
because after why he's becoming away
you're right saw it happen with joy
karate and I try to tell people all the
time people beg to bring it back instead
yeah I saw the numbers decline yeah and
after a while you look desperate so not
enough but you know what else is I mean
I don't know a lot of people don't
realize but because these younger kids
growing up all they watches YouTube
that's only one Cecily Lee's knows we
spoke about two weeks ago on the podcast
yeah I mean I did the AVN Awards I had a
show on the Playboy channel for two
seasons I had an MTV show I had all this
oh I was on Josh wolf show on CMT
nobody's man is not compared to the
anthem yeah but I was gonna say if it's
streaming if you did the dumbest show
him you didn't Marc Maron it streams
that beats all that [ __ ] on TV that's
what I was gonna say like once at least
once every three or four days I'll get
recognized from all deaf digital which
is just a YouTube channel but they have
like two million subscribers and I work
with them a lot I get recognized more
from that from this podcast from my
podcast more than anything and Instagram
like Instagram is like as powerful as a
TV at this point yeah I auditioned for
this place I love to get it
III die that put my time and I'm asking
for a half hour if they don't give it to
me I will not be metal it will not hurt
my feelings
yeah because I know there's so many
other avenues and you can monetize it on
whatever billion different channels yeah
exactly you know you shoot it but
nothing happens you put on YouTube I
mean that I said all these people you
talk to now or or they're all chasing
the same nickel that's kind of why like
it's when people are like what is your
goal I'm almost too embarrassed to say
it because it's not like necessarily
like a one-hour special but it's more
like this year I'm headlining a bunch of
dates my goal is for to sellout those
shows and however that happens like if
it's putting a viral video out if it's
continuing to grow my Instagram fits my
podcast growing I just want to keep
becoming more know
perspective that's like a downward down
now yeah narrow it down and write it
down it's not about that
just to become a better conduct well
that's like always the goal that's the
number one thing we have a better comic
a little sharper my riding up yo you
know it's so weird I you have to look
I'm so happy that in quit drinking good
I took these weeks off just to really
reflect on what material I was doing I'm
glad yeah because you never know you get
into a rut man and you have to perform
but also life is short you have to
perform but no it's not that wife is
sure it's that you want to come out with
something new and fresh so you take a
couple weeks off you get entertained and
you let the new you come up with those
thoughts maybe you're saying something
you shouldn't be [ __ ] saying because
it's not really it's not really when you
are changes things to get out of your
usual [ __ ] Groundhog Day routine you
know Lee a couple weeks ago asked me
Apple months ago and I almost [ __ ]
establish it goes do you ever believe in
taking a week off time you never take
them off I don't believe it I talk about
you to people because I literally like
you know I'm taking time well from stand
up yeah but I'm writing a board take
time long no no I take my room Ryan 500
words a day trying to write a [ __ ]
sitcom with my buddy on the phone every
day yeah give him trying to tighten up
the podcast and tighten up January and
end the year next week with you know you
have other avenues just because I'm not
doing stand-up
that doesn't mean when I don't get it
when I got up at 5:30
I let put that coffee I drink water now
first I drink a glass of cold water get
my body going then I go and hang out for
a while I smoke some reefer I drink some
coffee I'm gonna come to a morning joint
with oh my god and then by that time
everybody's [ __ ] up tormenting me
asking me questions and she and then but
what was the point the point is how hard
the whole the whole time like I said but
you never take a vacation ever
yeah
no way next we gotta take vacation beach
next week yeah you got to conductivity I
love you're going to Huntington that's
like an hour away yeah perfect it's so
[ __ ] that's a different one I love
owning ten I really do I know it's a
difficult I love it there
I love the pier different one what are
you gonna do down there hold it just
hang out my god I love that I know we're
supposed to Mexico we do it all the time
sometimes now she gets carsick
listen you got Wayne the child gets
carsick child so I can't take a longer
than a [ __ ] hour because and now we
got a change you're sure I'm not doing
it no more so well you know we made
plans to fly to different places but my
ear is [ __ ] up so we're gonna go to
Denver in February and I was gonna do
the economy works and then from there
meet that announcement and do the last
week of [ __ ] February and Aspen
gangsta style daddy snowboarder maker no
I can't 55 Michael just put her on the
[ __ ] slopes I'm coming with you I'm
putting her on the slopes too baby and
let her be a [ __ ] snow bunny for a
few days just get some food and relax I
was thinking about doing that my head of
the [ __ ] surgery and my ear and then
so I'm like you I'm in limbo - I gotta
wait to hear what they say I only got a
week a month until June I didn't book
heavy at all at all at all me happy yeah
yeah man but it also makes you better
yes you look at things now and I didn't
know about this guy's and I didn't know
about this I'm learning about this now
you everyone someone you gotta take a
minute and look back and reflect and I
had to reflect this as I got out of the
prison you know I'm saying
you also got a go away like that
Thanksgiving I talked about I mean it
was just a holiday but I just didn't
give a [ __ ] about like work my phone
social media I just spent a day just
chilling and having fun and I swear I
felt like I went to rehab for a month
like I just felt so refreshed from one
day of just chilling yeah I might do
social media come on I'm done till
Tuesday no
why I want what we're gonna do on social
media Friday if you if you're anybody
have you got a family of your legit you
don't have a family of you legit I don't
have nothing I'm covering my viola
listen if by Friday if you're on [ __ ]
social media
you better [ __ ] figure something much
I remember you and I got into this net
where was that good - so good way to go
yeah cuz you were like you don't need to
pose so much you only get so many too
much I look at these people and I go
they tweet everything constant 24/7 you
did tweet let people and you sit there
and go when does this end why I just
don't understand that sometimes I know
it goes I remember I see people tweeting
only one a [ __ ] tweet
I know sometimes I'll be sitting outside
smoking joining that just look on
Twitter entertain myself guys tweet at
me and they go you're the worst feed I
follow on Twitter you suck and I'm like
why do you follow me go away I [ __ ]
hate hate on people criticize you follow
to yourself take the [ __ ] night
[ __ ] off I don't need you that's right
it's Christmas [ __ ] let me tell you
something man yeah and then it mean in
that sense but it's the truth man if you
can't be on [ __ ] social media long
weekend it's Christmas weekend trying to
computer off who gives a [ __ ] about
podcast or what [ __ ] this guy had to
say or that guy had to say just [ __ ]
go for a walk and get some air into your
[ __ ] brain and with that again we
want to wish you a Merry Christmas we
will be back next week for one show only
again I want you to hang out and breathe
a little bit this show four shows down
your [ __ ] throat on holidays give you
the [ __ ] house it's time to get the
[ __ ] out of the house
you can't be in that house all [ __ ]
here nothing happens on the goddamn
couch so get your [ __ ] together but if
you need to get your [ __ ] together and
you want to get the party started
and you're a little light on Jesus let
me explain something to you you need it
and I know where you get it you ready my
bookies the place to score serious cash
on your sports predictions believe it or
not the holidays are just around the
corner what five days and while this
means plenty of parties gifts and most
important and most important spending it
also means that there's a lot of
football bowl games Pro all pro
basketball hockey or oh forget college
balls coming man up and play like the
pros on game day you can play the money
line side or total my bookie is your
hookup for all your betting needs are
you listening to me booked up for all
your betting needs and offers super fast
payouts
when you win which is what we specialize
in over there my bookie you win you get
paid that's the most important thing
where you bet is just as important as
who you betting on and if you want to
make money betting the games you gotta
go with my bookie AG doc why because
they're the only side I'd recommend I
trust them but you don't have to take my
word for it check about yourself
they got odds on every matchup and the
mobile site that makes wagering on your
smartphone or breeze listen to me
this is the time of the year you're
[ __ ] making killing especially this
weekend join now and my bookie will
match your deposit with up to 50% bonus
you ready 50% bonus you ready 50% bonus
use promo code Church to activate that
office CH you are CH visit my bookie dot
AG today and use promo code Church CH
you are CH you play you win you get paid
that's what it's all about at the end of
the day
getting paid you don't [ __ ] gamble a
look around and tell you goofball
friends look at me [ __ ] that go to my
bookie dot AG and do what you got to do
press code Church and they'll give you
it don't match your deposit with up to a
50% bonus oh my god
anyway let's stop serious now when you
write me a Christmas list which is over
if you didn't write your Christmas list
yet go [ __ ] yourself alright you're
[ __ ] up but if you did write your
Christmas list you better tell Santa he
still owes your money and all you want
for Christmas is a clean [ __ ] when
you got excess pine cones when you got
excess pine cones hanging from your
[ __ ] [ __ ] and some fudge you
putting smear all over your [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] ass on a holy night you need to
push your birthday that's right [ __ ]
but days are back it'll clean your ass
better any toilet paper on the [ __ ]
market plus you save trees plus your
finger don't go to a paper and your
finger banging yourself they got [ __ ] on
your fingernail then you rub your kid's
face and he gets pink eye
who needs that [ __ ] the touchy birthday
is the way to go it uses clean water to
spray your butt sparkling clean
providing you with shower fresh feeling
after every [ __ ] after somebody looks
dead hung up your ass and let's say
you're gonna get a ball lick you gonna
write the tushie I'll pull out your
[ __ ] helmet it scrubs your balls and
you dip your helmet in there clean the
jism off the sides of it go right to
Mama's room and pop in her mouth like a
[ __ ] soldier plus no more skid marks
no more sugar burns fairies hanging from
your ass crack was just an [ __ ]
cleaner than a white Christmas you
understand me
your [ __ ] will be tip-top Magoo plus
it kills germs and keeps the hemorrhoids
away listen this is the best gift you
could give somebody I'm telling you
right now listen go to hell don't push
me calm right now the thing up today is
portable birthdays that started $69 okay
Santa could afford you stop wiping with
[ __ ] - nasty toilet paper
and get a clean [ __ ] nice and clean
you dip your nutsack in there you pull
the [ __ ] skin back from your helmet
and you watch that [ __ ] helmet nice
jello - she does all this [ __ ] with nice
cold war that's what's a bond let's see
I'm gonna do your board you could sit
there all day and let that cold water
your [ __ ] on Christmas Day with you
in the only grandma's house for that
[ __ ] Christmas card with five hours
and Grandma
shovel it final hours up your ass I'm
gonna stay at home with my portable
birthday smoke weed and let that water
well ma'am tinkle my [ __ ] you
understand me
Donna hello - she calm right now a huge
coat Church for 10% off your
[ __ ] order you know I'm saying
they started $69 you know I love you
guys
this is just an idea for a Christmas
president again I want to thank my
bookie Dodd AG I want to thank K Quigley
think I want to thank the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys would be a family all year and for
being a great [ __ ] audience and for
letting us run our [ __ ] crazy in this
body and for coming to the shows and for
just all the support and love I wish you
and Lee wishes you Kate was the bottom
my [ __ ] comedian heart and you know I
got none but heart I wish you all a
[ __ ] merry happy [ __ ] Christmas
Hannukah what's the black one Kwanzaa is
her I'm in the Japanese one coming
deeper you [ __ ] bother my fat
little chubby heart yeah Merry Christmas
have a great holiday and we'll see you
next year tip off the [ __ ] New Year
right I love you stay black get ready
for this [ __ ] Jam tomorrow is just
Jones